so now I know you talk about Pixar and
how they have these sort of emotional
core that can humanize a robot pets all
sorts of you know right well the
emotional core is part of a bigger
picture the reason I use Pixar is
because first I'm a huge fan of Pixar
and their stories I've never been
disappointed with any of their stories I
think they're master masters are telling
a story and specifically about
characters and how to and connecting
with characters especially since most of
them are not human but the the emotional
core is really what I called at the
heart of the story so the heart is
obviously the character you care about
but that's one half of the equation the
other part of the equation is they're
they're what I call the worthy
motivation what is it that they trying
to accomplish in the story and why
should we care
in other words usually there's an
emotional stake from that goal so for
example Finding Nemo he has to search
for his son and something we connect
with we we we think it's a worthy
motivation somebody so that's funny most
or about fish are you in my in my power
seminar compared to similar stories in
this case both stories about fish and
the ocean one was Finding Nemo Pixar's
and I compared with shark tail which is
DreamWorks story and when you see when I
show the opening of Shark Tale and and
the introduction of Oscar play by Will
Smith you get you can see the audience
reaction when you compare the two clips
you know who they care about the reason
we don't really care about Oscar in
Shark Tale is because his whole
motivation is about getting rich quick
and about getting you know it's it's
something we relate to as human beings
but I've never seen a story a film story
about somebody who's trying to get rich
and that's really successful that's
appealing you know was that we root for
even though it's something that we do we
all like to we all ambitious and trying
to get rich and trying to better our
lives but you never see stories about
that why is that so because we don't
really consider it we realize not really
kind of a worthy thing it's not it's not
what it life is about right life's more
about
and connecting and and and helping your
friends and if you look at the the
motivations for the characters and Pixar
and have a slide with all all the lists
of all the movies that they did and all
the worthy motivation and 90% are about
saving the village saving a friend
rescuing a friend saving a friend saving
their mother searching for their son I
mean it's all relational so all
relationships really the lesson you get
from all stories at least from what I'm
aware of is that it's all about
relationships about connecting with
people so it's all about love so that's
the thing about Pixar so so you make you
make us connect with a character and
then we have to see them for two hours
doing something and we really have to
root for them to do that so the when
it's a worthy motivation then we root
for them and we're we're connected with
them and we we're engaged because of it
what are some of the questions people
ask you when you do talk about Pixar
because you were saying earlier that a
lot of people want to do sort of their
own biopic or they're you know just yeah
I usually get the writers who do
animation who come to the Pixar one and
so the question I always get is how do
how do I get my script the Pixar epic
start to do my script so which which is
easily answered because they do
everything is internal they do their own
you know it's all director driven so
whoever is that Pixar they do their own
thing and they don't they they've ever
seen them taking a script from outside
and making that so it's all internal
they may use a outside screenwriter like
they use Michael Arndt for Toy Story 3
and I think the original Toy Story they
had a whole bunch including Joss Whedon
but they most of it is internal so it's
only internally driven from a concept to
finish so the answer is forget about it
any other questions or that's the one
and and and then the other question I
get is you know about my character you
know they've gotten probably feedback on
their character not working and it's
usually because they're not doing what I
wanted Tom to do which is the whole you
know pity humanity admiration they're
just not using the techniques and so
they create the character
mostly you know maybe they're showing us
their trades but we just don't really
care about them and so that's that
you